what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk
all things marvel and mcu and of course
spider-man no way home and today we
actually have some news
that is kind of coming from sony i say
kind of because they put it out
then deleted it which of course means
that it was something that we weren't
supposed to see
that accidentally got put out there i'm
not really sure how these mistakes
happen but
it's fortunate for us because we find
out a little bit more than we should
and when it comes to spider-man no way
home we
love it we'll take anything we can get
at this point because that trailer has
not yet been released but i will talk
about that a little bit in this video as
well
and of course i'll be diving into what
the official sony pictures account for
argentina just released not even an hour
ago so if you love
spiderman and want to stay up to date on
all things related to no way home be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
also my new giveaway for a marvel's
avengers chair
is going to be announced within the next
couple of days so stay tuned
so somebody over at the sony pictures
argentina account the official account
on twitter
did something that they weren't supposed
to do this morning some spanish
title cards were revealed for spider-man
no way home but the argentina account
put out a
video now the video is of the title
being revealed in spanish
however the video actually revealed a
little bit more
than sony wanted to so i'll play it
right now and let's see if you catch
what i'm talking about
catch that at the end the logo and the
title
actually glitch now this is the part
that sony did not want us to see
they didn't want us to see the glitch
because it is kind of like the animated
into the spider-verse film and this
really does confirm a lot of things
about spider-man no way home
and we'll get to that in just a little
bit but first let me do a trailer update
because i know everybody has been asking
about that
and although we don't necessarily have
incredible news we do have an update
and it looks like we shouldn't expect
the trailer until later on
in the month or early july and this is
coming from
two different sources one source is
daniel rpk on twitter
and daniel's track record for trailer
updates has pretty much been 100
each time he said a trailer is coming it
came and this is what he is stating
probably towards the end of this month
or in early july then i had another
source a personal source of mine who has
also been
pretty much 100 right about all of the
trailers he told me that the eternals
trailer was coming and the chongqi
trailer was coming
and they came on the exact same date he
is now stating the same thing it's
probably coming
at the end of this month or early next
month and the reason for this is
these sources typically only hear things
right when trailers are about to drop
typically they find out a few days
before if not a week out at most which
is why
they're saying that it's probably coming
at the end of the month now again
movie theaters do have the trailer in
but these
trailers are very very secure and the
people who work at the theaters can't
watch the trailer they are locked away
and protected by a password and sony is
only going to give that to them
right before the trailer gets released
so apparently that hasn't happened yet
so we're still a little bit away
so that's my update for today on the
trailer but luckily sony pictures
argentina
gave us some things to be excited for
and kind of confirmed a few things
so the glitch of the title card at the
end implies that the multiverse is
glitching
this is much like what happened in into
the spider-verse where the multiverse
was glitching
and that's how we got the premise for
the movie now i've heard some people
kind of be concerned about this thinking
that they're going to copy the
live-action spider-verse straight from
the animated series and i definitely
don't think that that's going to be the
case yes it's glitching in the same way
but the glitch is just
implying that there's something wrong
with the multiverse which we already
know
that's how the spider-verse is going to
come into play and that's how the
multiverse of
madness is also going to come into play
as well so this isn't really that big of
a surprise but it is a confirmation from
sony
especially since they deleted the tweet
that's always a big giveaway
there are more confirmations that come
from this but first i just want to
explain
how exactly our multiverse the mcu's
multiverse is going to
so-called glitch and you can't see me
right now but i'm definitely doing air
quotes over glitch
the glitch or the breaking or shattering
of our multiverse actually started
in one division they didn't really give
us too many hints about this
but they did hint at it two times
specifically one time was in one of the
commercials for
a nexus pill and the other time is when
agatha harkness stated that wanda did a
probability hex
now we know that wanda didn't really
know hexes before she got her hands on
the darkhold which means she didn't cast
a hex per se but just kind of
made it happen this does imply that she
herself is a nexus
being nexus beans and marvel comics are
individuals with the ability
to affect probability and the future
altering the flow of the universal time
stream and this seems to be what wanda
is now fast forward to loki episode 1
very minor spoiler coming right now
they also mention a nexus event which is
essentially somebody doing something
that they weren't supposed to do
and a different timeline branches out
this could definitely be something that
wanda did
and perhaps we'll see the repercussions
of this in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness i would not expect
loki to address
this but i do believe it will be
addressed in multiverse of madness
but then of course loki has everything
to do with alternate timelines and
essentially a multiverse and i'm betting
it's going to be
loki who ends up shattering the sacred
timeline which is going to lead into
spider-man no way home and multiverse of
madness so as we can already see in the
mcu they are not
copying the plot of into the
spider-verse it is going to be different
but both do involve essentially glitches
in the multiverse but they
are caused by two different things now
another thing
that this confirms is essentially the
sinister six and the main villain being
green goblin
and at this point in time i think
everybody's pretty much expected green
goblin to be the main villain so many
people are reporting on this
and now with this leaked title card from
sony themselves pretty much confirming
the multiverse it's
really all but confirmed that the green
goblin is indeed going to be the main
villain and it
is going to be willem dafoe's green
goblin from the sam raimi universe now
with the green goblin is going to come
the sinister six and it's going to be a
sinister six
from multiple different universes so far
confirmed is alfred molina's doc ock
from the sam
raimi universe also jamie foxx's electro
from the amazing spider-man universe is
confirmed as well
and from there we have big rumors of
rhino showing up again
possibly sand man from the tobey maguire
sam raimi universe possibly the lizard
from the amazing spider-man universe
and i do love the different multiversal
villains but i do hope we get some
villains from the main
mcu universe that already know are tom
holland spider-man i hope michael
keaton's vulture makes a return
perhaps we could even get scorpion or
chameleon or perhaps even mysterio is
still alive and perhaps he could make
his return
in spider-man no way home either way
this title card reveal
from sony themselves does show us that
the multiverse and more specifically the
spider-verse
is coming in spider-man no way home in
fact i would be willing to bet that this
is the title card that they're going to
show
after they release the teaser trailer
they would put it on the end
they did release two pictures of two
different spanish title cards today and
i'm assuming that somebody released the
video when they weren't supposed to
but thought they were sucks for that
person but it worked out for us
at this point in time we pretty much
know it is confirmed to be a
spider-verse film we're just waiting for
sony and marvel to come out and say yeah
it is
and of course we're all waiting for that
trailer and waiting for that scene
where we see tom holland spider-man
andrew garfield spider-man
and toby maguire spider-man all standing
together i don't think we'll get that in
the teaser trailer but perhaps
in the main trailer but let me know what
everybody thinks about this
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of my
spider-man videos don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof